-Our next guest
is an eight-time Grammy winner
who is out with her new album,
"Denim & Rhinestones."
Performing "Pink Champagne,"
here is Carrie Underwood.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Adrenaline rising ♪
♪ Ain't feeling no pain ♪
♪ I'm floating and flying ♪
♪ Room is spinning,
making me sway ♪
♪ And I ain't even
had to go ♪
♪ And open up
a bottle of wine tonight ♪
♪♪
♪ I can go on a bender ♪
♪ Anytime that I please ♪
♪ Don't need a bartender
pouring over, serving me ♪
♪ I can get intoxicated
on you, baby, anytime ♪
♪ 'Cause you're mine ♪
♪ There ain't no last call
counting down on the clock ♪
♪ I can have all I want ♪
♪ Don't be cutting me off ♪
♪ 'Cause too much of your
good love ain't a bad thing ♪
♪♪
♪ And your kiss got me wishing
I could bottle it up ♪
♪ Every sip to my lips
is a sweet sugar rush ♪
♪ 'Cause your love gets me more
buzzed than pink champagne ♪
♪♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, yeah ♪
♪ I still like my rosé ♪
♪ Boy, don't get me wrong ♪
♪ But you're what I reach for
when I want something strong ♪
♪ Never hungover ♪
♪ But I can't stay
sober with you ♪
♪ And I don't want to ♪
♪ There ain't no last call
counting down on the clock ♪
♪ I can have all I want ♪
♪ Don't be cutting me off ♪
♪ 'Cause too much of your
good love ain't a bad thing ♪
♪♪
♪ And your kiss got me wishing
I could bottle it up ♪
♪ Every sip to my lips
is a sweet sugar rush ♪
♪ 'Cause your love gets me more
buzzed than pink champagne ♪
♪♪
♪ One more round of you
won't hurt me ♪
♪ I need you right now
in a hurry, baby ♪
♪ More buzzed
than pink champagne ♪
♪ Got me addicted ♪
♪ Don't wanna fix it ♪
♪ There ain't no last call
counting down on the clock ♪
♪ I can have all I want ♪
♪ Don't be cutting me off ♪
♪ 'Cause too much of your
good love ain't a bad thing ♪
♪♪
♪ And your kiss got me
wishing I could bottle it up ♪
♪ Every sip to my lips
is a sweet sugar rush ♪
♪ 'Cause your love gets me more
buzzed than pink champagne ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh, oh, one more round of you
won't hurt me ♪
♪ I need you right now
in a hurry, baby ♪
♪ More buzzed
than pink champagne ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]